Housing Department budget workshop and begin our budget workshop for
the Houston Public Library. In attendance we have Council
member Tasha Jackson, council Member Abby Cayman, council Member
Leticia Plummer and staff from Council member Tiffany Thomas and
Ed Pollard's office. All budget workshops will be conducted
in person. Only public speakers have the option to comment
in person or virtually 48 hours prior
to the start of all workshops. Presentation material are
uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies delivered to each
council office. All departments have been directed to
provide written responses within 48 hours
of the conclusion of their presentation. To any questions
posted by council members on SharePoint, the Budget Workshop schedule
is posted on the BFA website. Questions from council members can
be uploaded at any time during the budget workshop process.
Of course, the earlier the better, which allows the departments plenty
of time to provide responses. All public speakers should be signed
in to speak. If you haven't, please signed in on my left, on your right.
And my staff member Carolina will be monitoring the public speaker's list.
Public speaker's questions should be directed to City Council.
If a public speaker would like responses to any questions,
they should submit their question to their district council member or at
large members. Council members, the 2023 budget
amendment template has been uploaded to SharePoint.
And as Mayor Turner mentioned, all council
offices discussions on the 2023 proposed
budget will be handled there. Only operational budget related
amendments will be considered. Policy amendments should not be submitted
and will be ruled out of order. Amendments are due Wednesday
the 25th, a week from today. Today we
will hear from the Houston Airport System, houston Health Department
and solid waste. As a reminder,
only people attending virtually are public speakers. And we'll get
to their questions after the presentations and after the questions from council member.
It's my honor and pleasure to welcome Director Mario Diaz
and Curtisia Hampton.
Did I do right? Okay. Of the Houston Airport
system to provide an update. Good to see you,
Director. How's everything? This is going to be all about spaceport,
right? Shoot. Okay,
welcome. Good to have you all.
Also, before we start yes, your mic is on. Like to welcome
staff from Council Member Amy Peck's office,
marianne Huffman office, colossus Nero's
office, and Council Member Sally Alcorn, and staff
from Vice Mayor Pro TEM Martha Castek Tatum,
and the lady who just came in because
I parked next to her, council Member Carolyn Nevin Shabbat
and Vice Chair Edward J. Pollard.
Mr. Chair, council members, welcome and thank you for the
opportunity to share with you our insights into the preparation for
the 2023 fiscal year budget for the Houston Airport System.
What I'd like to do first is introduce the team. My team. As I've
said before, it is the team that gets things done.
In particular, I'd like to first introduce Jim Sesniak,
our new chief operating officer. I'm really, really delighted to have him on board
to help. We have Liliana Rambo, chief of Terminal and
also helpful with administrative matters. Of course, you know
Todd and you know Mayuri, the council liaisons.
We have James Stormsky,
who is the acting assistant director for Financial Planning.
We have Fruit Khan who is the budget manager.
We have Anna Guerrero and Uber
Khan and Tanya Harris, all three of whom are financial
analyst force. And they've all assisted in putting this presentation
together. And then next to me, of course, is Katisha
Hampton who will help me
with the presentation. Now, Katisha is actually the chief auditor
for the department, but since we lost our chief financial
officer not too long ago, I've asked Katisha to help
out pitch in and she's gladly done that. Of course,
Katisha really handles more of the accounting matters for
the department and I handle the financial analyses and
financial aspects of the finance
department. What we'd like to do today is I would
first like to take this in two parts. In the first part I'm
going to go through and talk about some of the accomplishments and some of
the forecasts and projections that formulate the basis for the
budget itself. And then Kirtisha will go through the
numbers. So, next slide please. And of
course we'll take questions. So the
first slide shows the budget cost centers for the department.
As you can see, we are proposing a total budget of $516.7
million that's total revenue and total expenses
and flow of to the
airport infrastructure fund. We have
a total of 1152 employees
or full time equivalents, and we have eleven cost centers.
Next slide please.
When it comes to accomplishments, I think there are just three that I want to
highlight and there is one Mr. Chair on the spaceport.
Be patient and we'll get to it in a second.
First of all, and this is the most important,
and it is that we've established Hobby as a five star
airport, the first five star airport in
all of North America by Skytracks. It is the first of the
60 odd airports that are tracked
by Skytracks. And it is really important because
it gets us to half of the way to our vision. Remember that
the vision of the Houston airport system is to create a global air service gateway
where the magic of flight is celebrated. The airport system
has two commercial airports. We have the spaceport,
but it's not a commercial airport. We have two commercial international airports,
both of them international. And we have accomplished the mission of
becoming a five star airport at Hobby.
We are now focusing with all our energy and focus
on intercontinental, to make that a five
star as well. Now this brings us, of course,
to a very, very special place in world airports.
Only 16 airports, 15 and ourselves at
Hobby are rated five stars around the world.
And it's an accomplishment, as I say. That brings us to the point where
we can now say the vision we are halfway there on
the vision of becoming a global air Service gateway.
Next. The next that
I would like to focus on is the accomplishment of itrip. That is
the International Terminal Redevelopment Program. Construction has
accelerated. We are very well into the
ground. We will be coming out of the ground with steel probably in the
June, July time frame,
the Deep West Pier. And you'll see if you come
to next Thursday's Economic Development Committee, we will be putting on a
presentation devoted totally to the International Terminal
Redevelopment Program. And we will be featuring a
section of that of concern that I know is probably on your minds today,
which has been on our minds, which is the roadway congestion.
So we'll address those things.
The D West Pier, which is going to be the first
installment to be completed, will be delivered on schedule
in June, July of next year, that is, we will have a brand
new pier. The rest of the renovation
of the North Terminal will be completed by December of next
year. And then in the June July time frame for 2024,
the entire project will have been completed.
We are due to,
as I say, make a presentation to the Economic Development Committee
on the status, the complete status. And really, it's to
talk about the scale of this project. And you're going to see some slides when
we come in next Thursday of the huge structures that
we've got to bring in and lift into place to make this project
happen. The third accomplishment that we're
very, very proud of has to do with the spaceport.
Next slide, please. So in
the spaceport, we have been really,
it can't be said in any other way, more successful than we
ever imagined we would be with this spaceport having
completed and brought into the spaceport
system three top companies that
together will, in a matter of 15 to 18 months,
have about 650,000
manufacturing space in the aerospace sector. These are collins
Aerospace, of course, is the division of Raytheon Fortune 500
company. We have intuitive machines that will be building the Nova
Sea lander rocket propulsion systems. They're going
to the Moon later this month, the first commercial trip
back to the Moon. And it will be from a company that actually produced the
landers and the propulsion system and navigation systems right
here in Houston. And, of course, we have Axiom Aerospace.
Axiom, as you may know, on May 21
excuse me, April 21 completed its
first flight to the space station,
delivering astronauts and coming back. And, of course,
last week, May 11, we had the groundbreaking ceremony for
Axiom at the Houston spaceport.
So we think that the
addition of these companies, the addition of this 650,000
manufacturing space will result in about 1000
to 1500 jobs, new jobs, well paying jobs within
the next 15 to 18 months.
Next slide, please. So what does the department
do? Well, I think our mission statement sums that up very, very nicely.
It is that we exist to connect
the people, the business cultures and economies of the world to
Houston. Today, we provide about 184 destinations.
From Intercontinental, 121 are domestic,
63 are international. From Hobby,
we provide 84 destinations. 76 are domestic
and eight are international. At Intercontinental,
domestic travel is exceeding international recovery,
90% versus 77%. The reverse is
true at Hobby. At Hobby, we're recovering faster
in the international 91%. And by the way, these are percentages of
2019 traffic, 91% versus 82%
for domestic. We have four airlines that are
exceeding their traffic levels at
IH against 2019. So they're doing better,
actually better than they were in 2019. We have four airlines
that are still in the recovery phase. We have one airline
that's gone bankrupt, was Interjet. They simply couldn't make it.
And we have two airlines, Ethiopian and Air China, that have
not returned yet. But we expect Ethiopian Airlines to return probably
in the summer of this year. And hopefully Air China will be
not too far behind. And then, despite the Pandemic,
we're very, very happy to announce that airlines like Allegiant,
Frontier, Southwest, American,
Caribbean Airlines, delta, Spirit, Suncountry, United,
Viva, Airbus, and Veladis, all added flights,
all added service during the Pandemic that we have
just transitioned through. Next slide.
So our strategic plan is fairly simple.
It's laid out, as I said, there's the mission,
and I've talked to the vision. What we are focusing
on is acting responsibly with
respect to social, environmental and
economic concerns. As I've mentioned, we are
generating jobs focusing on how to train the youth
of Houston for careers in aerospace manufacturing,
and improving the financial resilience of the airport system. That goes
to the second bullet, the International Terminal Redevelopment
Program, the Domestic Terminal Redevelopment Program that we're going to launch
as part of the capital program in the coming year.
And Southwest Airlines seven gate expansion
at Hobby are all platforms for future success.
And then, of course, we have collaboration with airlines, the federal agencies,
and concessionaires and contractors. All in addition to
the work that we're doing in shifting the culture within the organization
that addresses the final priority, which is to build relationships
and conditions for
betterment.
As you can see, what we really want to do is in
the next slide, please.
This slide shows traffic in graph
form. I'll have a slide that comes
right after this that'll simplify it. But you can see the vagaries
month by month, year by year. We start with
the blue, which is the 2019,
and then from there, you descend down.
I would just point to two graphs on this.
That is the one for 2022,
which terminates at 25.5 million. That's what we expect at
the end of this year, June 30, when we finalize the
numbers, we'll come out at about $25.5 million,
25.5 million passengers. And then for
2023, we're forecasting 29 million.
And that's just about 800,000 short of the 2019
all time high. Next slide, please.
This slide better shows the point that I was making
about the trajectory and the path that we're following.
As you can see, we started out in 29.8
million employments in 2019,
and then of course, we dropped off and we bottomed
out in 2021, fiscal year 2021. And then we've been
increasing to where at the end of this year, we expect to be about 25.5
and next year 29.8. And then we'll continue on from there.
And so that concludes my part of the presentation.
If there are no questions at this point, I'll turn it over to Katisha and
she will carry on with the numbers. Next slide.
Good afternoon. So I'm going to talk about revenues by
fund.
Oh, lord. Sorry. Thank you. I'm going
to talk about revenues by fund. And I'm really going
to home in on our FY 19
actuals versus our proposed FY
23 because our FY 29,
this is more because we dipped down during the pandemic.
But we are expected to either
match or exceed 19 with our
revenues and expenditures and our employments. So in FY 23,
we propose our budget is about 516,719,000.
In FY 19, it was about 518.
So we're about 2 million under budget for
I mean, under revenues to match 2019,
which we're back on track. For FY 22, we had
478. So our budget has increased
about 8.1%. And if you go to the next slide
so our budget has increased by 8.1%
over our FY 22 estimate. And our airline
revenues for landing and terminal rents are projected
to increase by 11.6 million.
Non revenues, parking will increase
by 12.1, ground transportation and terminal
concessions by 9.3 million.
And car rentals, about 4 million.
Revenues from facilities and other
miscellaneous revenues are projected to increase
about 3 million. And our other miscellaneous
includes ground rents, hangers rentals,
facility rentals, and interest income.
Next slide, please. We want to
show you our COVID related grants that the airport has
received. So and we've received about
460,000,000, which is 458,000,000
that we have received,
that we are eligible for sorry, that's available to us.
We've received as of April 30 of 2022,
we received 295,000,000.
Of that, we've used the entire 295.
So we have about 169,000,000 still
available for us to use for our COVID
related grants.
Next slide, please. And now
I'm going to go to expenditures. So our expenditures
for FY 23, we are proposed
to spend the 516,
719. And we can look at FY
19 we had our actual was 519
million. 519,000,000. So we're about 3
million below our FY 19 expenditures.
Next slide, please.
So our expenditure highlights,
we're about 4.4% increase
our expenditures and that is due to personnel increase
by 6.3 million.
Supplies and capital and supplies and non capital
equipment, we're going to increase that by about 0.2
million, about 200,000. Our contracted services are
increasing by 4.1%.
And we just want to point out here at the bottom,
we pay about 1.3 million and
3 million of our general fund is
services to the city for HPD,
fire rescue, HR, it legal
water and sewer, et cetera.
Next slide, please. So this is the
expenditures, the change in every line
item by category,
and I'm going to talk more about that on the next slide. So next
slide please. Oh, perfect, thank you. So this is our
FY 23, which is our expenditures
for 8012 I'm sorry,
which is our capital improvement. So it's about 26,000,001.
Three six. For our FY 23 and FY 19,
we're looking at about 3 million. And that is due to
our increase in all our 4%
increase in all our facility maintenance, our police,
fire, rescue act, aircraft rescue, utilities,
et cetera. Next slide, please.
Our expenditure highlights. In our capital outlay fund,
which is our fund 8012, our expenditures are
projected to increase by 828.7%
over our FY 22 estimate. And that is mainly
driven by our replacement of our has,
our fleet vehicles and HPD
vehicles. We actually had purchased vehicles in FY 22
and we did not receive them. So therefore,
they had to be rolled over into our FY 23 budget.
So that is mainly the reason for such a high increase
in our capital outlay. And we had about 0.7 in
our computer and hardware, computer hardware and software,
and about 0.5 million into our
furniture and equipment.
And just so I wanted to reiterate here,
we're buying 25 electric FY F
150s that those are in that fleet that
will be rolled over for the FY 23 proposed
budget. Next slide.
We wanted to break out our FY 23 budget,
personnel versus non personnel. And if you
look at non personnel, it was about 61%.
Fire rescue is the biggest portion of our
non revenue. But I also wanted to highlight
on our contracted services, so our contracted
services are a big portion of
our non personnel as well. And so some of our top contracted
services are our security contract, which is about 4.8
million, landscaping is about 1.6
million, smart cart is about 1.4
million, and our asset management is about 6.2.6
million. Next slide,
please. Here is a slide on
our budget history. If you look at our FY 23
proposed budget versus our FY
19, we are pretty much on target
with our budget versus our actuals with
our FY 19 year, because that is going to be
our year that we are comparing FY 23
to because our passenger levels are back around that
level. Next slide, please.
And again, we want to thank you for our
prep budget presentation hearing and to reiterate that
Hobby is the first five star airport in
North America. Any questions?
Yes, we have a number of council members in queue. We'll first go
to council member Abby Cayman. Thank you, Mayor Protem,
Director. Congratulations to you and
the entire airport system team, our partners at the airlines.
It's hard to know where to begin, right. With all of the success and progress
that's been made, whether it's at the spaceport or our traditional airports.
I wanted to just spotlight we have a lot of residents
that are continuing to enjoy the new child play area at
Hobby. When I was in there, I'm seeing it packed all the time. That's great.
The new pet areas. Can you remind
me? I believe you touched on it at the beginning, but there's been a lot
of headaches. Understandably so around Intercontinental
with all of the construction, and you've been
very responsive to those needs. But can you go back to
when residents can expect some relief there?
Sure. Thank you for the question, council member.
And so again, next Thursday, we'll have a much
more in depth presentation. But let me quickly tick off a couple
of points. The first point that I would make is that I think we're over
the hump on this one.
If we could do it over, actually, we'd have to do
it the same way. Here's the problem. It's real estate.
The way that we might have done it had we had the real estate,
was we would have built temporary roadways and put all the traffic on
the temporary roadways while we did the construction. But real
estate doesn't exist. We're in a canyon. Once you get into those roadways,
you've got parking garages on one side of the street, and you've got terminal building,
and we've got to work in those streets.
I think people don't appreciate the scale. And so please come
next Thursday so that you can understand the scale and you can see the
huge structures that we're moving on these caterpillars
and actually lifting at night and putting into place.
We're just not replacing the roof or replacing windows in a building.
We are completely redoing the entire international building.
But to the point precisely.
As of June 6, we will have finished the elevators
in the international terminal. Why is this important?
Because we could not bring handicap
passengers down to the lower level to take them through the tunnels
to the other terminal buildings. And so what we're doing is, once those
elevators are in place, we will take the buses that
were outside that were transporting passengers, and we will use those buses
will be removed, and we'll have another lane open that will increase the capacity
on the roadways. Number two, in July, United Airlines,
as you know, they're building that at the same time. And we
probably could have done a little bit better of coordinating with them on that.
But they're building this massive early bag short system because
they really want to grow in Houston. It's a 400 million dollar
investment. It's wonderful once they have it
in place. But they needed to take down the roadways, and they limited
to one lane. Now, they tell us that as of July,
middle of July, that lane will be improved,
and the departures lane will all merge so that traffic
should flow much more smoothly through that area. And then in October of
this year, that will be done. That project will be done, and roadways
will be cleared. June 6
of next year, we will have the first installment for
the, as I said, the Dwest Pier. And once that Dwest
Pier is opened, we will have a much better time and
movement of traffic off of the roadways on the north the
terminal into that area. And then come June,
July of 2024, the project is finished.
Now, that's not to say it's over, because immediately
we are now focusing on the infrastructure inside the
roadways. We're replacing all of the water lines, the water mains.
We've got to put in high pressure water, because once we
start councilman Robinson, you know that once we touch a building,
you now must meet the new codes. And one
of those codes means you got to be sprinklers. We don't have the water pressure.
And so the new early the enabling project
that we have for the water will provide tanks, provide new wells
and pumps that will and new lines that will be able
to keep the water pressure at high enough level to actually sprinkle
all of the buildings without having to have pumps and tanks in each one of
those buildings. So that will continue. And then next year, we're going to
be starting on the same project
just at the other end of the terminal. The terminal a redevelopment program.
It's another billion plus investment we need to
make because we need to continue investing for
the airlines. They've asked us for 17 gates. We have a plan.
We will be bringing that forward to Economic Development Committee as
well. So I do think that we are now really starting
to see the light at the end of the tunnel on this. And we hope
that as the summer progresses, things will improve continually.
If I could be placed back in queue. Council Member Sally
Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair. On page 14,
the $103,000,000 breakdown that you give to the that
goes to to the city, to the general fund. If I could just you don't
have to give it to me now, but if I could get a breakdown on
that. Sure. And and to Council Member Cayman's Point,
what what can we do in this budget cycle to help you
with the traffic situation? Is it HPD?
It's really hard to explain what you just explained to constituents
who call that's a lot of
moving parts. Is there anything else besides just
the things that have to happen to open up lanes that can be done to
steer traffic? We tell people, take the train to
A, we'll pick you up at A, or get the Uber from A or whatever.
I mean, what kind of practical advice or what can we do during the budget
cycle to help you. I think that the
one point that we try to make over and over. And I know we
do it lightly because we don't want people to think that they've
got to spend their life at the airport, but come
early so that you have enough time to get to the traffic
so that you are comfortable that you will make your flight.
And then here's the second thing we're doing. One of the things that we've noticed
is that what we call irregular operations. So for example,
let's say that we have once the flights launch from Asia, they launch from
Europe. They can't stop. They've got to continue. Once they're over the North Atlantic
or the Pacific, you just can't tell those airplanes to return.
But let's say the weather changes and we're
now in a thunderstorm condition. Those aircraft
have to be held. They start circulating at altitudes of about 1000ft.
They're stacked one on top of another. And of course,
I was going to go pick up grandma or my wife or my kids and
they were supposed to arrive at five. Well, guess what? The aircraft is still in
hold position and now I am circulating. So what we're going
to do as one of the measures that we were taking is
when we see this condition, we're going to open up the parking garages.
We're going to just let people go in. We're not going to charge them.
We need to get them off the roadways. We need to find containment areas
where we can get them off the roadways. And that way the traffic will circulate
much better. Okay,
great. And just congrats on the spaceport stuff too.
And on hobby. I mean, that's the most and to me the most exciting thing
going on in Houston, Texas right now. It's really great.
Council member. Cayman. Thank you.
Chair Director just as we talked about
construction, I just want to highlight and we can discuss offline the importance
of as we're looking at new plans and new facilities. We are
now the hub of innovation as we've always been. But that's really our thing.
So I want to make sure that as we're building, our buildings themselves
are pushing the envelope in terms of sustainability,
resiliency best practices in
terms of environmental sustainability.
Really quickly, I wanted to recognize you all at
the airports we got an increase in the minimum wage to 15, which I
think is a really remarkable and important thing to recognize.
My hope is that you all will continue to look again. We've just passed at
the city paid parental leave, going to
the next step in terms of our Janitorial contracts, our subcontractors,
things like that, to push to make sure that everyone is included in those things.
And if you all could provide just offline and we can submit the question and
update on the progress in terms of Janitorial
pay and things like that, I would appreciate that. Sure.
Finally, Council Member Alcorn asked it,
and I'll ask it a different way, given the constraints that
the city continues to face. I know the airports are succeeding.
They are doing very well. Are there any other needs that we should be
aware of that are coming up on the horizon that you want to flag for
us? I can't think of any. You've been very
supportive. We're very grateful, and thank you for everything
you're doing to support us on this. Thanks so
much. Thank you. So,
Director, nobody else in queue, I'll ask a couple of questions. So I'm looking at
your revenue page. $517,000,000.
Do we have any additional funds that come in from FAA
and all that kind of stuff?
Your budget is always the most difficult one to understand
because you have sources of revenue and expenses all over the place that
are not in the general fund. So we don't have purview to it.
If you look at the CAFR, it has four line items every monthly, and you
can't get much with four line items. So I'm trying to dig down into
everything you have coming in, everything you have going out,
including the what's our international stuff called
hasdc does
not well, I know, but it still has a
revenue stream. I get it. It's a separate organization.
I get it. But when it has Houston Airport system
on it, then I feel somewhat I
should be knowledgeable, but no one knows anything about
them. Maybe that's way it's supposed to be, I don't know. But getting back to
my original question, on the revenue side,
517,
is there FAA money? What does that amount to?
You make a good point. So let's look what what this budget addresses.
General fund is what we call operating revenue, right?
Operating revenue. Let's talk about non operating revenue from an accounting point
of view. So there are a couple of more line items on revenue that
we would address or we would bring forward for your attention. For example,
the biggest of those, aside from grants,
we'll get to grants in a second. We'll focus on a second. But the biggest
non operating revenue that we have, of course, is PFCs.
So we collect 450,
and we just multiply 450 times
30 million employments. You're at 120,
some odd million dollars, 120 plus maybe $140,000,000
of PFC revenue. Now, it's restricted with
respect to what we can do for it, but we can use it for four
purposes. Number one is to expand the national Airspace system.
That is, if we can use it for runways, taxways and things like that.
We can use it for terminal buildings. We could use it to security,
to enhance the security of the airports. We could use
for noise mitigation around the communities. And we have spent some
of that money, and we use it for competition to bring in new airlines.
So that's what the roughly 100 and 3140
million PFCs can be used for. And it's very helpful.
Principally, we. Use PFCs to write down the
debt service that we have to pay every year. That's how we use the money.
The second source of course, is in this case for the past
is the grants, the Cares Krisa
and ARPA grants. $450,000,000, that's a one off thing.
And as Katisha said, we've received about 300 million
of it. There's still about 160,000,000 or so to be
received and we're using those monies. We did use about 92
million of that debt, as you saw on the line, of 120,
some odd million to assist the airlines
because to the extent that we use grants, they didn't have to pay the debt
service on that grant. But again, the line
share as you see on that page, is really again to offset
debt service. And for next year we'll be using another 50 million
and then another 50 million. And that'll essentially
use up the remainder of the grants that we have.
2nd, 3rd item is grants, FA grants.
So we receive. And we
need to do a better job because we think that there's more FAA grants
out there to be to be obtained,
but roughly about $50 to $60 million a year that
we want to bring in on an annual basis,
either in terms of entitlements, because we are entitled to grants on
the basis of passenger traffic and cargo that we move through our
two airports. Our three airports. And then of course, the last one
is interest on reserves. We have about a
billion dollars in the bank and so inflation
is when interest rates rise. Of course that becomes
a fairly good source of additional incremental income. So those four
sources are not in these numbers, right? And before we
go, I know council Member David Robinson's in Q. Yes,
here's my problem, okay? And this is just a me issue.
I pride myself on trying to know everything about the
financial position the city is in, whether it's public
works, whether it's enterprise, whether it's general, whether it's airport,
and nothing. We have a guy who shows up here every
other week. He has a name very similar to yours and he sticks a microphone
in front of all of our eyes, ears and mouths
with questions that quite frankly we can't answer
and when we can't answer. And they show it, they love showing
it on the news to make us look like a bunch of idiots,
quite frankly. That's it.
That's part of the world we live in today. It's a lot different than,
you know, Walter Cronkite days, but there's a mission and
I feel so inept many times when I see
him out there and I run away from him because I know what questions he's
going to ask and it's going to be related to your enterprise and I feel
inadequate about answering it. I don't know how everybody else around here
feels, but that's just a me issue because there are so
many moving parts and you and I have had various conversations.
I've been here longer than anyone, and I trust you implicitly, and you do a
great job. And the Houston Airport System is
a well run, organized machine. Some of the things
we do there, especially what's going to happen down south,
is monumental. But FCC
money, general funds, revenue, all these different things.
And then a guy shows up with a microphone, and I just feel
unprepared many times. So that's why some of my questions dig
a little bit deeper. Ha SDC. I'd love to know what
more is there about the Houston Airport System Development
Corporation? We should be proud that we have airports that we run,
operate in Costa Rica, in other parts of the world,
nobody else is doing innovative things like this. So I'd
like to know more about it so I can educate the public who votes for
me or doesn't vote for me that they go, look at that guy, he knows
more about it. We trust him. But there are many times I don't feel that
way. But that's a me issue. David Robinson I
thought there was going to be a question at the end of all that for
the there is. Sounded like he might want to refer to my favorite architect.
Did you have anything you wanted to respond to? The chair the only response that
I would give is that we follow the
protocol. We follow the rules in preparing the budget and providing information.
If you would like a different format, if you would like to
expand the scope of the information, we'd be happy to provide
it. We're not looking to in any way shelter or restrict
information. We're just following the program here. Right.
And I think, Chair, that's part of the reason I wanted to hear that preliminary
answer, because frankly, my line of questioning was along some of the lines
you've pursued. And I've been fortunate enough to
travel with Director Diaz to some points
with mayoral delegations in South America.
We've passed through I've passed through not with you, but Ecuador,
Costa Rica. You've mentioned some of the investments that we have in the portfolio of
airports that we've assisted with globally. And it is really
something for us to be very proud about. And Director
Diaz, I think that is something that I share the Chair's interest
in knowing more and understanding about, but understanding
that that's outside of the budget, that you have
to operate your department.
That's kind of where I wanted to see if I
could take a moment and get your feedback on the
extra budgetary issues
that I've heard you talk about already today. There are
capital improvements that are going on at all three airport
spaces in the city of Houston right now. That's not what you use to
run your department on an annual basis, and it's really
not what's in our budget. And I'm thinking about how
we, with your help, could get to a better understanding
how some of those capital improvements go on concurrently while
you're running an airport system. And if you follow me,
this is where the things that the Chair and I
have been on the news along with you recently are
problems, whether it's congestion at the airport that you've
addressed with questions from Council today. I think I was
recently interrogated for why there weren't enough bathrooms
open. Did they interrogated? I think I did. And so the
fact that you didn't have enough bathrooms open became something that apparently
I should have known about. And I do care about the architecture
that you're investing in. And you know as well as I do that I've
had some serious questions for your design team, but that
is, again, extra curricular for
you. And as the director who I feel is the most
scrutinized, the most audited, and perhaps the most
or the least understood, I wonder if you could shed some
light on the separation of those basic components of
what you do every day.
I'm the chief executive for this organization called the Houston Airport System.
And right now, as I said, I'm very happy to
have Jim Sesniak, who is now the chief operating officer.
Jim made a very good point.
We had our enterprise meeting,
quarterly enterprise meeting with the entire organization.
He made a really interesting point that the CEO
focuses on the organization and the CEO operates
within the organization. So Jim's responsibly
enrolled will be on the operational side because
the capital side of this organization
is as large or not larger than the
operational side. When you really start to think about and again,
you'll see some videos. Last night we lifted in
place a section of truss that was 120ft
in length that was brought in
on one of those bogeys that was erected,
actually put in place right outside the airport because it couldn't
be transported. And we brought it in on 11:00 at night.
They started and they finished at 03:00 in the morning. Lifting this
thing by huge cranes and putting it in place. This is not
a small operation. It takes a lot of attention to
details. Councilman, as you know,
when it comes to design, you talk about design management.
I've been the design manager with your assistance,
and we've taken a look, and I have rejected many,
many designs, many, many proposals. I've said, no, that's not what we
want. We want something better. I have pushed the designers.
I've put them in competition with one another, and they've come up with a
phenomenal design for that terminal build. I think when this thing
next year, hopefully you will all come out for
the ribbon cutting for the Dwest Pier. You're going to see a
pier that is the first installment of a terminal
that you've never seen the likes of in this city. It's just
going to be beautiful. Absolutely and absolutely functional,
because we really want to pump a lot of traffic through there. Now,
having said that, I also have to focus on the finance
and I've got to focus on the business and chiefly
the negotiations with the airlines, because that's the difficult
part. Over the course of
my career, I've learned that you don't go into the office of a CEO
and say, hey, we want you to come to Houston or to Atlanta or to
New York. Well, New York is different.
Houston or Atlanta, and we want you to provide service and
you want to show them photos, because what they say to me is,
mario, those photos are really nice. What's the cost?
What's the increase going to be? How much assurance can
you give me about the control of costs in your airport?
What's the market? How's your economy going?
And you've got to be able to answer all those questions. So as the CEO,
I need to take on that role. And it's difficult.
It's something that it's not a five day
a week, nine to five job. It's a day a
week job. It is.
And thank you for that. And that's why we try and our responsibility
is to direct everything to you, not to them.
As a board of directors, sort of for the city, we have to go right
to you and we hold you accountable. We don't want to go to
your people. So this is our big chance to
get an opportunity to do that. Council member tarsha Jackson thank you,
chair. Thank you. And my
colleague, what he just mentioned, that trying to understand the airport and their
budget. I mean, airport is in district b. And so it's been a challenge for
me trying to understand your operation. And so I would love to just
spend more time with you guys so that I can just be
able to represent my constituents better. And so
hopefully we can do that soon in the future. But I do have a question
about the ARPA dollars. You mentioned that you give the ARPA dollars
to airlines. And I'm just trying to understand that. Do the airlines
apply for ARPA dollars themselves? No, we did
all the applications as the city of Houston, department of aviation,
houston airport system, and all
of the cares act, the Chris act,
and the ARP act dollars were provided to us
by formula generally. The formula is
that there's a pot that the federal government has available for airports,
and you will get the proportionate share of that
pot relative or related to the proportionate share that
your airport in terms of passengers,
represents to the total passengers across the country. And that
percentage we get, we've done pretty well.
And then the question is, well, how do you use it? And you remember during
the depths of the pandemic, one of the questions that
came up was how do we help the airlines, how do we help the concessionnaires?
And you can see in the Krisa act, there's actually
a line item out for crystal concessions. And this is money
that we were to pass on. We couldn't keep it. This money that we had
to pass on for the concession years, which we did, which is about 24
actually, total of $30 million. And then the rest of the
money, it's a question, we could use it for any lawful purpose
of the airport system. And we decided that one of the
best use of that money was to help our airline partners to the tune
of about $92 million. But that's it. Now we move
forward and we're spending the rest to carry our contracts,
our sky train parking contracts, manage those,
use that money for those, and then of course to write down
the debt service so that we get to a net debt service payment
that we can very well afford. Okay. Council member Cayman.
Thank you Chair. And to Council Member Robinson's
point, I appreciate that perspective, right minutiae of the
day to day versus overseeing all that you
are overseeing, which is again, not just our airports
and not just global expansion, but galactic
expansion, for lack of a better word. So I appreciate
you, I've never known you to be anything but responsive
directly to me, to staff, your staff included.
So again, I just want to recognize how far
we've come and the instrumental nature in which our airports play.
Again, it's under economic development because of all the things we're doing,
without the airports, we can't bring people in. So just wanted
to recognize that. If I might, just one last point that
I would make. It's not about me.
As I mentioned at the groundbreaking ceremony,
I might be the idea guy, I might be the strategist,
I might be the visionary, but it's these individuals
and the entire 1100 members of the Houston airport
system that make happen what has
happened to this point. And I'm really, really proud of them. They're the ones
that get the job done. Thank you. Council Member Sally
Alcorn. Thank you Chair. And I think you addressed most of this in
your response to Council Member Jackson. I appreciate you having slide twelve in
here to talk about the Krisa and the ARPA and the Cares funding.
And I think I heard you say I was going to ask and I'm always
blown away by when he just blows a billion dollars in reserves.
I mean it was a billion dollars in reserves before the Pandemic. It's a
billion dollars in reserves now because
of this money. Correct? That's pretty much it.
And then this 162,000,000 left,
I think you said you're paying down debt with it and honoring
some contracts and we'll be covering the parking contract.
It's about $30 million. And then there's the sky train contract
as well that we will be covered. Okay. And then that's
the end of and then that's the end. Got it. Thank you.
So of the $207,000,000 of debt,
how much is that is related to itrip?
Very little. Very little. What is that mostly related now? We only, I think,
in 2021, we fixed out about 265,000,000.
That is, we transferred it from commercial paper to bonds.
And I think the interest rate on those was three and a half to 4%.
So there's not a lot. As a matter of fact, one of the things that
we will need to do again, from wearing the financial hat is this
summer and into fall, we will be undertaking a financial
feasibility study. Because sometime between now
and February of next year, we will need to be back into the capital markets
to draw down and fix out the commercial paper
that we spent today. We've got $350,000,000 of commercial paper.
We need to unload that, fix it, and then secure
another $350,000,000 to finish out the financing
for itrip. So I would say that by the end of, let's say
June, July of 2024, we will have fixed out and again, the total
amount in terms of bonds is likely to be about $750,000,000.
Total bonds, total cost of I trip will be 1.3
billion. 1.3. Right. Okay. And expected
completion date June July of 2024.
2024. Yes.
And no other council members give me my last question. I know that always
tell people, if Houston Airport was a
company into itself, it'd be a Fortune 500 company. It's that big. It's a money
making machine. Billion dollars in
liquidity. Right. It's a very successful business,
but yet we're still the city of Houston. And I understand
recently good to have Jim here, but I understand we lost a
COO. I understand we lost our CFO.
That's why Ms. Hampton is probably sitting in your ability
to recruit and maintain employees, given the dynamics
of what we have to operate under. So two
things are happening. First is that, as you all know,
the great resignation is affecting us all.
And it's an employee market. Employees are basically calling their
shots. They're establishing what they want in terms not just of pay,
but also the benefits that they're available.
And then some opportunities are opening up. So our
chief commercial officer left to become the
CEO of John Wayne in California.
Let's talk about this for a second, because, again,
building leadership is also part of my job.
We start out with biodari. Baron Biodari,
former COO. He's now managing the world's busiest airport
as the director of Hartsville Jackson Land International.
Lance. Little former CLO. He is
now the managing director, seattle Tacoma.
Right. Okay. I'm sorry. No, I was answering Seattle
Tacoma. Right. Yes. Seattle Tacoma. He was awesome. He is now the managing director of
Seattle Tacoma. We had Ted Kitchens, who was formerly
running Intercontinental. He's running now an airport as executive
just outside of Boston. You have Perry Miller,
who was running manager of Hobby. He's now running
richmond, Virginia. And we now have Charlene
Reynolds, who came in very, very short sprint and is now
managing John Wayne Airport.
And so when it comes to the CFO,
the gentleman walks into my office and says, thank you for
everything you've done. I've learned how to sell
and finance debt in the capital markets.
You got to pay me for that now. I said, wait a minute. We did.
We gave you the education. Yeah, but I've
got a baby coming. I've got a new house. I need more money,
and they've offered me more. I can't match it. And so
we just need to move on, and Leticia
is doing a great job. Thank you. Yes.
I look at you and I would say you're closer to your
end of your career than the beginning of your career. So we're going to be
faced with where does the replacement for Mario Diaz come from?
Is that person internal or external? That's something to discuss on
another day. We have a number of public speakers that want to ask questions,
so thanks for the opportunity to get
into it. We could probably sit here for a couple of hours and talk
about airport because I'm sort of a geek.
I find what you guys and ladies do every day sort of
fascinating and always tell everybody, we'll be down in spaceport
tonight. We have our redistricting meeting at Space Center. And always
tell people, when we moved here in 1990,
hobby was this little bitty sleepy airport to the south of us.
And now it's a huge international airport that wins a
five star international airport that wins great awards 20
years, 30 years from now. Love to envision what spaceport is going to
look like because it's going to change the landscape of that area
with phenomenal engineering jobs and opportunities
and things of that nature. So keep up the good work,
team, and look for bigger and better things
for you in the future. And I would also recognize
Mr. Icken, who's very involved in your operations as well.
Maybe you'd say too much. Right, Mario?
Thank you. Okay, thank you. Thank you.
Dismissed. We'll have a couple of oh,
by the way, council member Robert Gay goes joined us and
now has another meeting.
Mr. Jason Oliver, I think, will be joining us virtually.
Star six. Yes. Good afternoon.
I'm really appreciative of the art I'm seeing throughout the airports, especially local
artists. I was in IH last week, and there's one
artist, Kane Smith, whose tapestry doesn't have a nameplate. It's a small
thing, but I just want to know who to contact to make sure
that's addressed, because I think it's important people know the artists whose work
they're seeing. And then I guess this question is
toward Council Member Martin.
Many of us are really concerned about the procedural change,
removing the public's opportunity to speak publicly to city staff during
these budget workshops. This is not consistent with previous
years and is now our only opportunity to do so after the
committee meeting. Policy change during the pandemic, which I hope will
also be reversed this change midway is a significant inconvenience
for those of us taking time out of our work day to participate.
It seems like this was your decision. Are you willing to resume
the normal policy that we started this budget cycle with?
And if not, please explain why public participation is being directly
undermined this year. Thank you for your comments.
If public speaker has any questions,
the appropriate process is for those questions to be submitted to Share
Point under your name through your council member. Thank you.
Now, that was a question to you, Council Member Martin. Well,
Jason, I just answered it,
so that's enough. Next speaker,
we have Miss Sava Blanding.
Good afternoon. Good afternoon.
City council members. Last night, I had a conversation with
my husband about the day's budget hearing, as one does,
and I asked him how he would have responded, and he said,
I would have asked, what are you afraid of? He commented on how there were
only seven constituents asking questions about HPD.
Yesterday, the first department finished 14 minutes ahead of time.
If time was really an issue, it is upon the council to keep everyone to
time. However, there were at least three to four repeat questions about Mowing schedules.
In the middle of Rush public testimony, there was an unrushed conversation
with another Houston Police Department employee. This is not about time.
To have given public speakers a full three minutes would have only
added 14 minutes, which the General Services Department's
punctuality provided. Why is the public not allowed more time?
What would those 14 minutes have cost the city, other than at least a humble
nod to democracy? Regarding the airports,
what are plans to improve public transit to access the airports?
And what are efforts to include and promote more local businesses in the airport system,
such as local restaurants and local retailers?
Thank you. Ms. Blandy.
Mr. Oliver had a question.
1.75% of all of our vertical construction
dollars go to the arts within that facility.
So percentage 1.75% of the total
vertical spend goes to the arts
within an airport. Your pictures,
paintings, different types of things. Council Member Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Chair. Thank you, Ms. Blanning, for coming. Again,
trying to get clarification on your statement
question, as it pertains to
the what are you scared? Part, is that directed towards
council, as in why we aren't allowing more time?
Yeah, I mean, I understand time is an issue,
and nobody loves punctuality more than me.
If I'm running a minute, a meeting is going to be like, 15 minutes.
But we got 14 extra minutes because General Services Department was punctual.
And then it felt like I was watching people
run out the clock because there were literally three to four questions that were exactly
the same about Mowing schedules. And then when it came to public comment
and we're taking time out of our day, it's 1 minute.
We're rushed, we're not given answers, and we're told just to submit it.
What's the point of this? We're supposed to be
a democracy. Well,
I appreciate your comments. I think the main reason for everything
is to get the public clarification on any questions that you
may have. And sometimes the questions
and the answers go above the time that
we reasonably have. So we have the process in place
that if the questions and answers aren't provided in a timely manner,
then you can submit those questions. Because at the end of the day,
as constituents, you all have rights to know any
answer to any question that you may have. And so if the point
is to ensure that you get the questions answered,
then we have that ability to do
that. And so I don't want to get caught up too
much in the different systems and process, because we all may have different
opinions and perspectives on that. But if your end goal
is to ensure that you have more information and
more clarity based on the questions that you may have, then we do
everything we can as a council to provide those answers to you.
Council Member Jackson. Okay.
Yes. Thank you. Saba I mean, that was one of my questions,
was we have the airport here in the police department.
They should be able to answer the constituents questions. I would want to get my
questions answered. If I'm sitting here in this chamber,
I would like to get the questions answered. So I would like to understand why
isn't that possible? Can we next year schedule these
hearings for the workshops? An hour. Each department
spend an hour to give people time to get their answers.
I'll let you get their questions answered. You and come while I go through
the next and you all can discuss it back there
away from the public. That's not appropriate for the public. We'll have Mr. Broder butler
next. Or I'll join you back there.
Good afternoon. I have no direct
questions at this point in time in regards to the airport.
I think that the Houston Airport does an
above average job. In other words, it's not exemplary. But I am
very proud of my airport. I've gone through many in this country.
But I do have just one concern, and now
I am getting to a question. I'm from Northeast Houston,
and I would like since Houston first is an initiative,
everything about this city is an initiative. I would like to have asked
the director, who is on the other side of the door and probably on the
fourth floor now, what would he do? Or could he put a
program together to make sure that since his
airport is in District B, where I come from,
that he puts a program together to try to get employees that
live within a ten to 15 miles radius of his
airport to increase on time, to increase his workforce?
But I don't get a chance to answer that question because he
talked about being a visionary. He talked about doing things that would
build up this city. And unfortunately, unless somebody
else can ask me about the vision of the director of the airports about
hiring practices, I can't get that answer.
So he puts on a program twice a year. I believe it is
out in that area because I live a little bit north of you
and I forgot what he calls it. But it's
an opportunity for prospective employer groups
that want to work for the airport to understand a little bit
more about that process and also the MWBE process
that should help those types of businesses, also individuals
who are looking for opportunities as well. So he does do
that in conjunction with a number
of folks within his airport. And I don't know where they are today
with it, but I'll try and find out because it just reminded me
because of COVID we haven't had many of those opportunities.
But it would happen literally twice a year that
he would put on a convocave that
had those opportunities for individuals as well as businesses
in particular in that area. Well, thank you for the answer.
With all due respect, the marketing of that doesn't get out to the
basic level of people. But I would also like to extend
an additional request, if you could ask him if funds allow, if time allows,
that he can increase it from two to four. In other words,
create a bigger net to cast more people. Because at this point
in time, using this great resignation,
you still got to bake the donuts, right? Do me
a favor. Send my district email,
district e at houstontx. Gov an
address so I have your email address and I will copy
you on the email I send to Mario Diaz asking that particular question.
One last note. You have a very exemplary staff every time I've interacted
with them. It's been a pleasure. Well, thank you for saying that. And there's
one of them sitting right here and I agree with you.
That concludes public speakers for Houston Airport system.